[Music]
and now a message to the President of
the United States you are a jackass
there have been many words to describe
you during these verse two and a half
months of this human waste treatment
plant of an administration of yours and
I have used most of them demagogue liar
idiot despot simpleton trainer schmuck
[ __ ] buck passer puppet lunatic
toddler fascist jerk
schmuck dope dipstick lame brain
but after prolonged consideration you
are a jackass you are president jackass
who else but a jackass would look at the
dying children of Syria and have as your
first reaction to blame your predecessor
when your fred assessor did exactly what
you aged him to do at least 37 different
times just on Twitter who else but a
jackass would have as your second
reaction to do nothing to stick to the
policy that most benefits Russia who
else but a jackass would have as you
were third reaction to put the
international balance of power at risk
in case our troops happen to kill a
Russian in Syria because your daughter
the schlock Meister one who tries to
turn everything she can touch into a
marketing opportunity she reported to be
ran to Daddy and said she was
heartbroken and you should thus go kill
some people who else but a jackass would
have as your fourth reaction to warn
Russia that our missiles were coming
knowing Russia would likely warn Syria
and then may even have puts the lives of
American service personnel at risk so
they could run a farcical stunt attack
on an airbase with instructions that
they should not try to destroy the
runways from which the Syrian jets
carrying the sarin gas that killed those
kids took off who else but a jackass
would have as your fifth reaction when
America finally woke up to the
nauseating reality that you put our
people's lives at risk to run a phony
photo op missile strike that didn't
strike much of anything to tweet that
everybody knows when you bomb an airbase
you never bomb the runways because
they're so easy to fix you are a jackass
you are president jackass who else but a
jackass would
his nitwit son-in-law to do anything on
behalf of the American government when
he just happened to fill out the forms
for the top-secret security clearance he
doesn't deserve in a million years and
he came to question 20 B point six which
asks about substantial meetings with
foreign governments and he forgot to
mention his meetings with the Russian
ambassador to the United States who else
but a jackass would trot out this
Kushner this triumph of double nepotism
after this to borrow some names from
Louise mensches Twitter feed all over
North Face somehow acting in the name of
our democracy wearing flax 5th Avenue
and a pair of jim oakley sunglasses who
else but a jackass would say how many
weeks he'd been in office and get it
wrong by a margin of eighteen percent
who else but a jackass would accuse
Susan Rice and Barack Obama and the
intelligence community of crimes without
one shred of evidence among them but
continually defend vladimir goddamned
putin who else but a jackass would claim
that an eleven term democratic
congressman from baltimore had told you
you will go down as one of the great
presidents in the history of our country
and leave off the part where he said
that to perhaps become great her should
have to stop dividing and harming the
country and start truly representing
everybody you are a jackass who else but
a jackass would demote sorry rhea comma
dates a man like steve Bannon not
because he has no business being
involved in running anything more
important than a popsicle stand but
because you reported we were embarrassed
that Saturday Night Live made him look
like you're a boss and you weren't
quoting of all places Fox News happy
with the way Bannon had been grabbing
the limelight who else but a jackass
would let Homeland Security try to
trample the First Amendment to unmask
one of his critics on Twitter who else
but a jackass would have escaped
disaster during the campaign after the
Access Hollywood sexual assault tape yet
still publicly defend a serial sexual
harasser like your pal Bill O'Reilly and
claim he'd done nothing wrong
who else but a jackass would accuse a
New York Times reporter of being the PR
person for Hillary Clinton and when she
replies mostly by you though you replied
no no no mostly by a
a lot of people like you're 12 freaking
years old who else but a jackass could
have a collection of pet television
hosts propagandists so stupid that they
would not think to delete four year old
tweets that prophesied your NIT witted
policy glad our arrogant president is
enjoying his taxpayer-funded golf outing
after announcing the US should take
military action against Syria you are a
jackass president jackass and worst of
all worst of all
maybe worse than everything else
combined so far who but a jackass would
approve his first high-profile military
mission and see a Navy SEAL named Ryan
Owens lose his life while fulfilling
that mission and then exploit his widow
during your speech to both houses of
Congress saying the same day this was a
mission that was started before I got
here this was something that was you
know just they wanted to do my generals
are the most respected that we've had in
many decades and they lost Ryan jackass
you worthless jackass you president
jackass